questo video andava fatto mille anni fa
perché non so quanti di voi conoscono il
pop coreano che sarebbe che hip hop al
giorno d'oggi ci sono gruppi che vengono
idolatrati perché fanno queste cose
sembra che stiano soffrendo tutti di
diarrea in questo momento però c'è steve
aoki per farla breve io nel 2012 2013
era andato pazzo per una canzone
fantastic baby dei big band o un esempio
un attimo una veloce
se tu provi ad ascoltare per bene il
coreano sembra che dica delle cose
italiano che non hanno un senso di
esistere
adesso vi faccio vedere il significato
vero della canzone fantastic baby ci
siete
[Musica]
perché morì ping pong
adesso noi dobbiamo fare reaction a
questa roba
la dura
[Musica]
bene
la cima
ai due re magi pago 2 sorbetti al limon
iniziate ad ascoltare che hip hop vi
prego che ha un senso in tutto c'è un
senso e non so che ti filosofico e
magico vabbè poi ci sono queste rivolte
a caso che non ho neanche mai caldo
visto miliardo di volte sto video e non
l'ho mai capito bene però dove band
avevo dubbi che il pane fosse da
mangiare prima che diventa duro e po un
casino
[Musica]
madonna soldi le macchie di sangue
acer
gli sci baracche cane in gol va bene a
parte tutto questo ma perché dovresti
esaltarti così tanto semmai un cane
dovesse ingoiare qualcosa come fate a
non nasco come fate a non conoscere la
roba voi dovete questa religione non è
canone musica e religione
[Musica]
cambiate
questa di tutta la canzone è la prima
più bella perché se la ascoltate
veramente ma veramente dice col cup che
non so se lo dice veramente non può
essere altro con quello ha detto
[Musica]
giovanni dare in joy mente sempre
tersiva
a ritagli agosto cane però dov'è
wow francese baby poi un fake slow
motion incredibile facciano finta
anche se un orgia
dai che c'e un orgia ora se voi non
conoscevate questa roba non meritate di
vivere per me sta roba era la religione
o risultato ogni volta che ho visto un
cane ingoiare qualcosa da sempre ho
sempre mangiato il pane perché è sempre
stato da mangiare e col cazzo che non ci
[Musica]
basta obama perché ovunque
ma mara voce un nome cerca un nome che
c'è un nome che non è che un manager
napoletano
[Musica]
la gara perché
assente
[Musica]
a regà mi raccomando se non credo al
mango siamo tutti i morti ci mangiano i
coreani meraviglioso regalo la musica a
me piace nel senso che io ascolto
ascolterei di continuo perché mi
piacciono casi nostre canzoni ei
[Musica]
no
cosa stiamo ascoltarlo per lavoro di dio
allah ci mangia e luca e molliccio e se
il pandolce niente al prossimo natale
siamo tutti nella merda perché voi ci
mangiano i coreani o ci mangiano i
pandori pure anna ci mangia un casino
[Musica]
da noi
a pensavo luca
[Musica]
ma no
ma quel che è ma no non è temi ripresi
[Musica]
il riassunto e che luca molliccio anna
mangia tutti bye bye pisellone la vorrei
evitare anche per questo debiti e
tramite troppo quali primo va bene da
guardate cosa cantano davvero non quello
che pensate questo cantano perché
parlano sempre gyan
[Applauso]
[Musica]
diceva veramente così anna sono cazzi
tuoi mondo
ragazzi io io conoscevo sta roba per
volevo portarla perché secondo me va
vista cioè king lugano non l'ha vista ti
sei perso la vita zio adesso sapete
realmente di cosa stiamo parlando quindi
quando ascolterete una canzone coreana
in realtà sapete che dietro c'è un
significato nascosto
vi chiedo scusa se vi sono sembrato un
po appena sveglio durante tutto il video
però sono appena sveglio cioè questo sta
la mia mattinata tipo ascoltare che hip
hop e italianizzato e fatemi
assolutamente sapere se volete faccia
reactions un qualcos'altro in qualche
cosa ti polke hip hop su cui vorreste
che io facessi vari action per il
prossimo direi che possiamo concludere
qua perché già verrò sommesso di
copyright almeno non nego facciamo
privado a mangiarmi pane che da mangiare
io compro qual video ragazzi come senso
che mi è piaciuto come mi piace anche
vari social convinto descrizione tesoro
si schieri e ci rivediamo lo posso vedo
ragazzi non so quanti di voi conoscono
il copy il coc coreano
[Musica]